é possível chegar à lua com mas bolatti
está em 32 culpa ae
[Música]
imagine só tentar incomodar algum
vizinho com isso léo gago eltinho e
magia a iochpe uma macaca vou fazer o
melhor que ouvir essas cartas que eu vou
guardar dentro do bolso a lei dentro do
golf e agora vou vir agora olha aí é
[Aplausos]
essa energia pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos ainda e
leão e os trabalhos aqui mais um vídeo
do laser lei com um pé e não está a
prever porque o corpo está muito
iluminado mas só pra ver um exemplo
muito grande e não só deu pra vocês
deixarem os vossos comentários com
alguma sugestão presta serviço a série é
possível que vocês comentaram é possível
o laser chegar até a lua e outro é
sugestão de fazer isso só vamos tentar
ver se isto é você consegue chegar até
luís jácome tempo só o que vocês acham
assunto a chegar até a lua sim ou não eu
particularmente acho que já sei a
resposta mas vamos tentar até mesmo já
sabendo primeira história aqui dessa
série como existe muito aqui neste vídeo
para eu continuar a usar o laser em
outros vídeos 68 muito curioso porque
tenho muita idéia era usar o exame mas
eu só vou continuar se você se apoiar em
muito este vídeo sério é muito
importante mesmo estão sendo subscritos
aqui no canal sabendo só que exclui não
só aqui no canal e advance nem pra não
perder nenhum vídeo tá muito calor aqui
no quartel a esse luxo aqui ó ó calor lá
pessoal vamos tentar responder então a
nossa pergunta é possível chegar ao
lucro é neste momento são 22 horas da
noite ou seja ela está bem lá no youtube
e já viu berilo e ela tá com as luxa ou
seja vai dar pra fazer essa experiência
muito bem mas antes de implantar a lei
geral eu vou tentar fazer com que
algumas coisas em casa à noite
imagine só iluminar a china cuba e
usuários que é preciso mais à noite
tentar incomodar algum vizinho com este
laser de bola muito longe e nem vai
saber de onde vem mais um ou então vai
né pouco mais e deixar rasto mas eu vou
tentar não ser apanhado eu vou fazer
muita coisa louca por aqui à noite
portanto se quiser ver mais vídeos 12 à
noite
é eu acho que vai dar certo lei civil
caac câmera e vamos lá por fora e não só
aqui fora e lua tálita lá no fundo está
bem lá em cima' lu e uma das primeiras
coisas que vou testar e tentar iluminar
e china a lei embora lá 321 vai rolar
isso ele mesmo fica muito sul e china
[Música]
ilumina muito só vou usar aquele padrão
porque eu gosto muito deste são várias
bolinhas
falei muito lucro ok agora voltar às
piscinas agora ela tá pronto tem agora
32 um vai o outro ilumina muito lá em
baixo no youtube a pesar menos foi isso
que o domina tudo week
[Música]
só mais um só estilo minas jogos todas
para isso eu vou tentar usar aqui o
padrão imaginou juntar os padrões de ser
todos os dias até mesmo a lei
o encontrei que outro padrão que é muito
bom também acho que esse padrão vai
iluminar tudo lá pessoal 321 vai
ocupando muito o nome na casa toda
f-1000 do até que um minuto tudo muito
bom essa não ilumina tanto a china mas
funciona eu vou tentar apontar lá
profundo tudo para lá 31 vai chega mesmo
até lá olhou foi do meu é muito lindo
esse feito ele isso é curioso pessoal
porque isso vai gerar muito muito longe
eu não sei se vai chegar até a lua olhem
só 321 vai olívio foi muito alto
ele está exercendo a mesma ter o seu
acesso com infinito ou tocaram em uma
estrela
olha aí toda não se conseguem ver uma
stack uma estrela e vou tentar tocar
nela 3 não vai sair assim que chegou
nós não chega muito medo de as pessoas
deixarem as casas lá no fundo onde até
aquelas com a casa do vovô vai ficar vai
ser só vou tentar apontar para aquelas
casas já no fundo eu não sei se vai
chegar mas vamos estar resolvido vai o
uhuu chega mesmo até as casas foi isso o
que é isso não incomoda os vizinhos já
que aquelas casas são muito mais longe
a lei chega a mesma tela só vou tentar
abrir que foi expulso e obriga que faz
duo celas quando muito mais a luz então
vamos tentar ver o que acontece para lá
três vezes não vai
o unirea isso o nelson passou muitas
partículas de poeira do arguido lesou só
vocês não consegui ver aí acho que doar
eu acho assim há tanto o ensino assim
como eu aqui dá para ver muito bem aqui
mais perto da próxima e itapevi muito
bem as poeiras e meio na mentira
medeiros e aproximar a mão e se logo
esse tratamento que ela quer salvar o
toque que achou muito a mão muito
potentes coisa eu vou plantar está assim
vamos ver se ela ilumina
23 e agora ilumina muito mais
basicamente os players efe como flash
lite também fica uma lanterna só ainda
tenha um árbitro muito mais longe eu vou
tentar acertar nela 321 vai horas
funciona mesmo
iluminar a futura ao fundo meu cérebro é
muito bom
a lei é difícil assim luís pisco ticos
meus presse universo é muito estranho
aqui acho que cinco estrelas são feitas
pessoal nos maior
olha aí imagine escutar o meu não falou
muito o braço e cortava um é um e já
tinha cortado a isso atingir o carro
acaba mal tem que ser província por fim
o italiano quatro vou tentar atingir o
pico lorenzo fez um vôo obrigou o
goleiro rodrigo jean hernanes fez aquela
estrela lei
acho que é uma estrela como assim
é muito perigoso queimar lá sua outra
coisa muito interessante é todos os
comandos ultra violeta tudo o que seja
suficiente isto vai dominar ainda mais
de 5 por cento olhem só não sei se vou
conseguir ver mas eu tenho uma bola cor
laranja muito por cento e eu vou tentar
apontar o laser para ela 321 vai por aí
não sei se conseguiremos ter uma bola
bem curva já a brilhar
olha aí tá bem aqui a bolinha está muito
funk ao vivo eu acho que provei e só vou
tentar atingir uma pessoa tem um desenho
assim alguém que tem a janela aberta e
vou tentar fazer isso mas não façam isso
em casa ou capital e sempre gozo e não
incomodem os nossos vizinhos mas eu vou
fazer porque seus clientes
eu preciso estar em mim é a minha 1 a 0
vou tentar encontrar uma casa como a
janela aberta mas não dá porque é muito
ruim o capitólio e ao fundo há uma
janela aberta no fundo muito o fundo não
se conseguem ver mas eu vou tentar
acertá la para lá 321 vai eu acho que
está a chegar lá mas não tem muita
precisão é muito longe e não consegue
ficar um exilado preciso toda janela do
vizinho a última janela tenha luz acesa
mas vou tentar aprontar pra lá só então
ver essa casa aqui e também que esta
janela em um dia vou tentar acertar eu
espero que não dê bosta embora o a321
vai imaginar que alguém está tentando
dormir ou com laser dentro do quarto
só lá em cima você está em uma boa
situação e procurar que também ensina é
a construção do triângulo tem uma
estrela outra estrela aqui e outra o
ator faz um triângulo é a construção do
triângulo para encontrar mais
construções
mas não há só é pena o pessoal tá fora
de casa só o pierre está em casa e é
muito bom você estar o pessoal aqui mas
infelizmente não estou em casa mas mesmo
assim vou tentar iluminar a casa toda é
ela e eu vou tentar abrir foi excluído
que obriguem denomina mais lei ilumina
tudo isso é que o pessoal
a próxima área próxima e agora é o
momento de nós responderemos a pergunta
é possível chegar à lua culé para lá
estar em 32 culpa vai rolar isso olha
isso acho que não me sinto hoje
ae como assim meu
[Música]
obviamente que os resposta para esta
pergunta nem a lua está a mais de 380
mil quilômetros daqui do planeta terra
portanto é completamente impossível este
laser chegar até a lua nesta série que
no máximo vai uns três quilômetros eu
acho o dois então isso é muito pouco
imagina só o lula seria de 380 mil
quilômetros só de que é isso é muito
longe tem que ir mais longe do que ir
mais longe e até a china milhões do que
contra dizendo meu mas é muito mais e aí
está a resposta pessoal não é possível
ficar a lu kolesny polícia fica fraco
laser
olha eu estava em poder optar pelo mesmo
com pilha fraca e vou tentar ficar ainda
mais na lua olha só
[Música]
só usei até já está a ficar sem pilha
então esse é o momento de acirrada que o
nosso vídeo espero que vocês tenham
gostado pessoal e já sabem se quiserem
continuar a ver vídeos do laser deixei
muito aqui neste vídeo e se inscrevam
que o canal eu vou ser muito feliz agora
em breve e que em cima vocês podem ver
dois vídeos entre os tão bom nível
técnico tanto passei lá e aqui em baixo
mais uma vez vocês podem se inscrever e
só fiquem vai até a próxima